accéder aux Champs-Élysées ce matin
relevés du parcours du combattant très
gros dispositif policier double barrier
rage rassemblement interdits
sont placées sous haute surveillance car
les autorités craignent des mouvements
d'humeur et des casseroles contre la
réforme des retraites
la tête d'Emmanuel Macron qui qui
tombe on va la voir et avec cette ce
titre voilà peut-il rebondir
donc si ce sont battus c'est pour
justement avoir aussi des grandes
libertés de la liberté de me poser la
question de pouvoir moi y répondre la
liberté aussi syndicale et de manifester
mais en tout cas je pense que une
journée comme celle-ci c'est bien de
faire preuve de retenue le président de
la République remonte les Champs-Élysées
accompagnés de la grande escorte de la
garde républicaine
puis Emmanuel Macron passe les troupes
en revue cette image des Champs-Élysées
vides désert vidés avec des gens
éloignés avec un périmètre XXL restera
malgré tout aussi c'est l'histoire qui
rejoint l'actualité ces personnes
séropositives pourront bientôt être
militaires le ministre des Armées
Sébastien Lecornu annonce avoir pris un
arrêté en ce sens elle pourrait donc
intégrer la gendarmerie les
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris et de
Marseille et l'ensemble des forces
armées
vous pouvez interdire comme le
gouvernement le fait les casseroles en
fait elles auront lieu parce que les
gens sont en colère et cette colère elle
est légitime on continue votre petit
calendrier c'est à dire que le 14
juillet aussi
la leader du rassemblement national
était sur ses terres électives dans le
Pas-de-Calais ou des porte-drapeau du
Parti communiste ont joué les troubles
fêtes durant la cérémonie
c'est un moment où toutes les familles
françaises pleure en quelque sorte ou se
souviennent de leur mort et je trouve
que venir en faire un tintamarre
n'est pas approprié ces ingénieurs sont
les lauréats du concours Lépine cuvée
2023 les voici honorées du Prix du
Président de la République symbolisé par
ce trophée un vase en porcelaine de
Sèvres il s'appelle drift une paire de
roues équipées de rétropédalage cela
permet de ralentir le fauteuil sans
frottement avec la main et en faisant 5
fois moins d'efforts pour l'ensemble de
son œuvre un Windsor d'honneur au roi
Charles III parce que franchement son
air consterné ses vêtements de carnaval
et heureusement ses oreilles qui
permettaient à la couronne de tenir à
peu près convenablement pas le physique
une silhouette qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue lors du couronnement de
Charles III
certains spectateurs ont pu apercevoir
une figure troublante passée en
arrière-plan faisant penser à la
faucheuse regardez d'habitude sur les
cocus qui sont au balcon là on a deux
glands là c'est quand même autre suggère
que ce serait plutôt Mégane Markle
déguisé certains vont plus loin et
pensent qu'il s'agit du fantôme de Diana
venant récupérer sa couronne
de quoi laisser entendre que le tour de
William arrivera plutôt que prévu
comme elle est de Tokyo à Paris un homme
âgé a lancé de la peinture sur fuck
abstraction une œuvre de Myriam Khan qui
a fait polémique puisqu'elle met en
scène un enfant et un homme dans une
posture sexuelle dès le début de
l'exposition elle a fait réagir les
associations de défense des droits à
l'enfant qui demandait le décrochage du
tableau car selon eux ils représentent
un viol mais le tribunal administratif
et le Conseil d'État avait rejeté il y a
deux semaines cette demande Emmanuel
Macron a toutefois condamné l'acte de
ventalisme vient un tweet sans prendre à
une œuvre cette attentée à nos valeurs
et gros bisous
[Musique]